[Música]
ninguém mais tem ouvido ninguém eu não
sei exatamente quando isso começou a
acontecer mas não foi assim que nos
ensinaram
vamos relembrar o momento muito
importante na nossa vida chamado jardim
de infância lembra walking dead assim
nesse batendo ea gente era só ouvidos só
isso
olhos atentos ouvidos atentos a gente
prestava muita atenção a gente focava no
cerco estava naquele recinto que sabia
mais que a gente era muito claro aquilo
tinha a professora alguns chamado da
apatia e ali a gente aprende simples
muito simples esponjas de conhecimento
professor ensinando a gente ouvindo
prestar atenção e tudo certo
quinze anos depois ao se perde
estamos na universidade no mercado de
trabalho
e parece que nesse pequeno tempo a gente
engoliu todas as enciclopédias que
existem no planeta até parece que a
gente faz todas as pesquisas do google
na nossa cabeça ea gente vira não sabe
tudo a gente tem certezas absolutas
pouco tempo depois a gente grita a gente
usa as redes sociais
a gente fala para o outro que ele não
sabe de nada somos gênios
de repente gênios da humanidade bem
assim
eu sei que quando a gente é jovem a
gente tem que ser extinto juvenil se
entende isso com 20 anos 1821 vá lá
agora continuar assim com 40 anos de
idade
quarenta anos de idade achando que é um
génio da humanidade a gente perde coisas
absolutamente importantes para qualquer
ser humano porque a gente já sabe tudo a
gente perdeu
curiosidade a gente sabe tudo a gente
perdeu inquietude se perdeu e ficou
nessa linha do jardim de infância
aí alguém vai ter que ser amigo de vocês
alguém vai ter que falar aqui cara é
triste que eu falar que não sabe de tudo
aliás está a léguas de distância e saber
de tudo e quando é que não saber de algo
também virou problema país tem gênio não
saber de nada sobre paisagismo futebol
política brasileira
nada que a gente fala do einstein todo
dia a gente conhece a língua do einstein
né
a gente conhece a genialidade do jovem
simples não tem problema algum não sabe
de algo
outro deles charles darwin charles
darwin
ele é um multi tarefas a fazer várias
coisas ao mesmo tempo e ele ficou oito
anos da vida dele está mais ou menos
dois mil novecentos e vinte e poucos
dias estudando uma coisinha chamada se
ip de ter uma idéia do tamanho é a
metade da cabeça de um alfinete darwin
focou estava inquieto estava inseguro
sabia que não sabia e aí partir daí o
tempo oito anos tentando descobrir o que
se passava com um ciep e aquilo ajudou
ele é tornar público
uma teoria pela qual a gente está
falando de charles davy muito estranho a
gente perdeu também a capacidade de
entender que a gente pode
pelas coisas da minha avó passou dos 90
anos de idade
um dia recebi uma ligação que vinha de
santana do livramento é uma cidade no
oeste do rio grande do sul pertinho
pertinho não colado com o uruguai
eu estava muito mal muito mal já estava
no hospital eu moro longe pega o carro e
vai viajando pensando que posso chegar
lá direto para o velório na minha mão
mas não dona é dona ele segurou
eu cheguei no hospital e as notícias
óbvias óbvio não eram notícias boas
ela já tinha perdido a capacidade de
distinguir seres humanos quem era quem
distinguir tempo para ela ontem a uma
coisa que aconteceu há 30 anos mas por
cilma milagre para alguns ou
coincidência eu cheguei no quarto da avó
ela me reconheceu e olha lá
sussurrou algo que pediu para ficar
pertinho dela pra quem é magrinha e aí
eu fiz um movimento que a gente não faz
eu fiz o seguinte movimento ela estava
deitada e eu joguei a minha boca
tagarela pra lá
botei meu ouvido pertinho de onde sairia
a voz dela e aconteceu uma coisa com meu
corpo que é um milagre
os neurônios todos se prepararam só para
ouvir e não para ouvir com a angústia de
falar imediatamente depois eu só deveria
ouvir a minha avó era o momento dela eu
só tinha que ouvir a e ouvir sair da
cidade
alguns dias depois essa é uma informação
que minha avó tinha morrido e óbvio que
ela faleceu cercado de carinho porque a
minha volta é uma coisa muito legal e
que a gente adora nos seres humanos e às
vezes a gente não consegue colocar essa
característica para a gente ela era uma
ouvinte todo mundo chegava para avó e
contava suas histórias que vão ouvir
via ouvia e como não o via e ouvia e
ouvia ela sabia mais o que no final das
contas a chegada não faço aqui
carinhosa e assim se despediu da minha
vó mencionou a ouvir
simples assim isso é mais estranho tudo
porque a gente vai perdendo a capacidade
de ouvir você já deve ter passado por
uma situação muito corriqueira que é
quando a gente tá vai conversar com
alguém
a gente faz o seguinte a eu tô indo pra
europa eu já fui lá eu fiz não sei que
ela vai pra casa de cara eu não te
perguntei eu quero te contar
ouve se não te perguntava olha só eu tô
indo pra europa tem dicas da europa e
fala em outra coisa
meu filho passou no vestibular o meu
passou em segundo não te perguntei eu
não quero saber do meu filho estou
falando do meu filho me ouvir
quando a gente não é interrompido quando
começa a falar porque a nossa angústia
falar falar falar e não houve e hoje
recentemente está vivendo um outro mundo
onde a gente consegue falar sem ainda
com áudio mas também na escrita
eu tenho certeza absoluta que todo mundo
em grupo e debates ap
eu tenho certeza absoluta que a gente já
mandou longe um monte de prime prima nem
aproveita isso porque todo mundo
perguntando do grupo swatch sap
ninguém tá ouvindo ninguém mudou de
opinião na minha família ninguém todo
mundo gritando e ninguém mudando de
opinião simples treta de grupo de dança
teve gente que aproveitou as últimas
eleições aqui no brasil para acabar
casamento logo olha não voltou no mesmo
que eu saiba tocar mais porque porque
quem tinha bolha a bolha que a gente tá
é quentinha todo mundo concorda tudo
feliz de ver que eu não saiba dar um
grito e volto cá a lenta os mesmos link
as mesmas idéias
a gente perdeu a curiosidade a gente
perdeu a inquietude isso é muito triste
e eu estou ainda berrando
eu sou um deles
mas um dia eu pensei eu quero ouvir mais
as pessoas que trabalham com comunicação
e eu falo bastante e um porsche chamado
potter entrevista nesse podcast buscar
pessoas que pensavam completamente
diferente de mim sobre alguns assuntos
que eu coloquei isso
olha é um esforço houve alguém que a
gente discorda
só que depois parece que se abre um
portal ea gente começa a prestar atenção
e aquela pessoa que discordava 100% já
está em 80
já em 50 porque está podendo falar 'eu
não interrompe a ela e ela fala ela fala
ea fala e mesmo que discorde depois quem
ouve podcast tire as suas conclusões só
quer ouvir simples
então chama alguém que concorda discorda
no final das contas eu misturei e já não
sei mais o que acontece
e aí eu entrei na marra maravilhosa
bagunça de descobrir que não tenho
certeza de nada
ouvindo pessoas a descobrir que eu sou
um completo ignorante está maravilhoso
assim é bom saber da ignorância porque
aí isso traz de volta a inquietude traz
de volta a curiosidade
simples assim ouvindo pessoas e
perguntando se deus existe
eu coloquei no estúdio o ex-jogador de
futebol e comentarista de tv casa grande
que escreveu um livro contando a sua
luta contra as drogas e tem a palavra
demônios porque uma infinidade dos
produtos químicos que colocava no
cérebro dele ele via demônios e aí um
ateu que escuta se emociona com
casagrande dizendo que o caminho para
sair disso pra voltar pra família para
as pessoas que ele ama para conseguir
trabalhar numa rede globo que é grande
muito grande com audiência gigantesca de
milhões de pessoas foi deus tem que
ouvir isso ouvindo também um médico
palestrante escritor e professor chamado
j j camargo
ele conta uma história de uma aluna de
um grupo de alunos porque estava vazia
quando um mala de pessoas que estão por
aí
outro lugar que não mais o planeta até
morrer e eles foram visitar essas
pessoas geralmente câncer e aí tinha um
homem que estava no quarto que ninguém
queria falar com ele porque ele estava
ainda ativo e não conseguia falar mas
ele estava ativo e ele podia morrer a
qualquer momento
erro médico conta que uma menina lula
topou entrar lá e ele deixou entrar
sozinha quando ela saiu ela conta a
história que esse cara falou com ela mas
de uma maneira diferente
ela chegou e viu que tinha um retrato
dos netos dele e falou são os netos mais
lindos dessa aqui
ele pegou a outra mão e colocou em cima
dela
só isso foi assim que ele resolveu falar
pra ver aquela menina não chorou depois
que ela disse que ela chorosa muito
chorona e sair dali
talvez com as principais altas de
medicina que ela teve porque ouviu ela
falou e ouviu a gente perdeu a
capacidade de ouvir uma empresa que quer
acabar com a morte
não quero aqui não tem como ficar é
infinitamente em grupo de artes ap ouvir
a nossa voz gritando eu quero sair antes
do dia que vai acontecer é isso que
antes eu sou obrigado a rapaziada valeu
já era não bagunçado estou ignorante
estou que é a melhor época da minha vida
é uma coisa engraçada porque às vezes a
gente não consegue conversar com quem
pensa diferente da gente mas não sei se
a gente já notou que tem um o maior
passador de informação curiosidade
histórias da que toda a história desse
planeta aqui ele em silêncio fala pra
gente eu tenho certeza que todo mundo
tenha em casa chamado livro o livro fala
ea gente fica quieto
tomara que não tenha ninguém agora aqui
fica batendo boca com o livro lento eu
não quero conhecer essa pessoa se ela
ficar batendo boca li o livro fica
continuar falando mas área a zaga pessoa
discordei pega um outro livro que pensa
diferente é simples
é assim que é a gente tem ainda o livro
nós também podemos salvar o bagunçado
ignorante e eu estou muito feliz
ninguém mais ouve ninguém mas parece que
tem jeito porque por alguns minutos
eu falei pra vocês ficarem em silêncio
discordando ou concordando comigo ou
seja talvez seja esse agora aqui um bom
começo para todos nós
obrigado pela atenção de vocês
[Aplausos]